رفضت سلطات السجون الاسرائيليه طلبا
الافراج المبكر عن الاسير وليد دقه بالرغم
من تدهور وضعه الصحي وافادت مراسله
الجزيره بان لجنه الافراج المبكر احاله
قضيته لما تعرف بلجنه الافراجات الخاصه
المخوله ببحث قضايا اسرى محكومين بالسجن
المؤبد علما ان الاسير دقه يقبع في سجون
الاحتلال منذ 38 عاما وكانت مراسلتنا
افادت بان متظاهرين اسرائيليين اعتدوا على
عائله الاسير وليد دقه وعدد من الداعمين
لهم في وقفه تضامنيه امام سجن الرمل
الاسرائيلي حيث ربطت قوات كبيره من الشرطه
والوحدات الخاصه عند مدخل السجن بتزامن مع
مواصله عشرات الاسرائيليين التهجم على
المشاركين في الوقفه التضامنيه للاسير
وليد دقه
الان ينضموا لنا بل تنضم الينا من امام
السجن الرمله مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري
نجوان مرحبا اذا دعينا يعني في تبعات هذا
القرار الجديد وعدم الافراج عن الاسير
بظروفه الصحيه هذه
هناك نقاط هامه جدا في هذا القرار اولا
هذا يعني بان اي قرار قضائي من قبل هذه
اللجان او من قبل المحاكم الاسرائيليه
يتماها عاده مع السلطات الاحتلال وقرارات
الاحتلال هذه اللجنه هي لجنه الافراجات
المبكره العاديه عن السجناء والاسرى
وبالعاده تبحث بمثل هذه القضايا تحديدا في
حالات المرض واسباب اخرى يتعرض لها الاسرى
او السجناء والنقطه الهامه هنا هي ان اي
الوقت هنا ثمين جدا الاسير وليد دقه في
المستشفى في قسم العنايه المكثفه جراء
حالته الصحيه حالتها صحيه الصعبه جدا بعد
ان تم تشخيصه باصابته بنوع نادر من امراض
السرطان وتداعيات ذلك عليه الا ان هذه
اللجنه اليوم ترضخ لضغوطات سياسيه مارسها
بالاساس وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
المتط وايضا مجموعات من المستوطنين ضد
الافراج المبكر وتقرر هذا اليوم بانها
ليست اللجنه المخوله ببحث الافراج المبكر
عنه وتحيل ذلك الى لجنه اخرى لجنه خاصه هي
عاده تبحث في قضايا الاسرى المحكومين
بقضايا توصف بالقوانين الاسرائيليه بانها
امنيه او الاسرى في المحكومين بسجن المؤبد
واللافت هو ان قضيه الاسير وليد دقه هي
تتجاوز قضيه الاسر المؤبد وليد انهى
محكوميته قبل عده اشهر بالسجن الذي فرض
عليه بالمؤبد في عام 1986
الاتهامه بالمشاركه والتخطيط في عمليه
نفذتها خليه فلسطينيه بقتل جندي في حينه
تم الحكم عليه بالسجن المؤبد وتم تحديد
المؤبد ب 37 عاما وليد انهى هذا الحكم حسب
القانون الاسرائيلي الاسرائيلي المخول
ببحث قضيتها حاليا هي هذه اللجنه اللجنه
العاديه لكن اللجنه لجنه الاستثناءات او
لجنه المؤبدات يكون هامش قرار الافراج عن
الاسرى عاده ضيق جدا
وحاليا وليد يقضي عامين اضيفا الى حكمه
على مخالفه او على ما اتهم به من ادخال
هواتف نقاله لاسرى او المشاركه بذلك اضيف
هذين العامين رغم انه في حالات سابقه
لسجناء يهود على سبيل المثال تم فرض عقوبه
غرامات ماليه بسيطه او
العزل الانفرادي لمده ايام قليله الا انه
تم اضافه هذين العامين لي وليد وهو
عمليا وفق القوانين الاسرائيليه سجين او
اسير عادي وليس اسير مؤبد مع ذلك ترضخ هذه
اللجنه لمطالب المستوطنين ولمطالب سياسيين
اسرائيليين متطرفين بعدم السماح للجنه حتى
بالبحث في قضيه امكانيه الافراج المبكر
وسيتم تعيين جلسه اخرى للجنه المؤبدات هذه
اللجنه بالعاده يتم تعيين جلسات متباعده
وبالتالي هي تتجاهل كليا الوضع الصحي
الخاص والحرج للاسير
شكرا جزيلا لك